President Trump has a new governing
theme a build a wall and crime will fall
if the glove doesn't fit I don't know
there are a lot a lot of things that
rhyme do walls work or are they merely a
symbol of security we will analyze then
Democrat representative alon omar
doubles down on smearing the covington
boys nick sandman goes on The Today Show
and the culture of death kills from
America to Holland
I'm Michael Nolan this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
this is the greatest evidence yet that
Donald Trump is listening to Alan
Dershowitz that his new governing theme
is build a wall and crime will fall Alan
Dershowitz famously on the dream team
defending OJ Simpson if this glove does
not fit you must acquit and build that
wall which will be good for all and and
the president is really tall I don't
know I like rhymes actually do work as
they stick in people's minds and
President Trump is absolutely right
about this theme
build a wall crime will fall we'll go
through all of the evidence but first
let's make a little money with a new
sponsor untuck it oh how I love untuck
it here is a tip listen you know the
Vanity Fair called me a dapper Lib
triggering troll I always try to take a
little care for my appearance and no guy
looks good if he has a button-down shirt
or an oxford shirt that's all bulky and
it's untucked and it's hanging down to
your ankles that doesn't look good
that's called a nightgown fellas don't
wear it you might think it looks casual
you might think oh I'm really cool I'm
yeah I'm apathetic
mm-hmm it looks awful it looks very
sloppy because the shirts were never
meant to be worn that way they were
meant to be touched
those are Tucket shirts these are
untucked shirts which are made
especially to be worn untucked and they
look super sleek I first found out about
them I saw some ads maybe on Facebook or
saw that looks interesting then Jeremy
boring the god-king is a an evangelist
of untuk --it so he starts wearing these
sure I said wow that's a good-looking
shirt he said oh it's untuck it Michael
because I'm a cool guy and I'm a Russo
okay great so I knew I had to get them
then not too long not too short for that
clean casual look that you can wear even
at the office they have more than 50 fit
combinations they look great on tall
short slim and athletic guys of all ages
go to untuck accom or visit one of
untuck it's fifty stores across the u.s.
and Canada actually went to a none
Tucket store here in LA it's great
they'll size you up they'll fit you into
a shirt fabulous product promo code MKS
for 20% off your first purchase if you
want the perfect fitting shirt
regardless of your shape and size try
the original untucked shirt remember to
use promo code M K s for 20% off your
first purchase you will love them build
the wall and crime will fall
the left is saying walls don't work this
is their new line walls don't work walls
don't work
walls are immoral walls are ineffective
walls are really terrible walls are too
expensive they don't work this is what
they all say but they do work obviously
this argument doesn't make any sense
they say walls don't work and they're
immoral well why are they in Moore
they're saying they're immoral because
they keep people out but if they keep
people out then they work they say that
walls are too expensive the president's
only asking for five billion dollars
which is statistically zero of the
federal budget but do they let's just
take on that we know that walls are
perfectly moral we know that walls are
not terribly expensive do they work do
they work well let's look at some of the
walls that work do they work according
to a DHS secretary former DHS secretary
Elaine Duke they work not only around
the world but in the United States on
Yuma they built on the right right by
Yuma in the United States agents were
arresting 800 people per day
trucks were crossing in with a lot of
drugs not through ports of entry but
through little vanishing points where
they could disappear really quickly and
you couldn't catch them so around 2005
you had this huge number of illegal
aliens pouring in in 2006 Democrats and
Republicans came together for these
secured fences Act of 2006 this is back
when Chuck Schumer and Hillary Clinton
and everybody was supporting building a
wall before they hated building a wall
because Donald Trump wants to build a
wall when they built that wall within
one year apprehensions across that
border dropped 90% they were 1/10 of
what they were before 2005 as of 2016
Customs and Border Patrol have saved
nearly 4,000 near-death individuals who
were lost in that desert AEI
has even more examples AEI showed a
great list of these the American
Enterprise Institute in Israel there's a
they have a border wall with the West
Bank they didn't build the border while
60 years ago or 50 years ago they built
it in 2001 2002 after a campaign against
Israel terrorist campaigns
how did the wall work then well
successful terrorist attacks dropped 90%
after they built that wall same number
that we're seeing in Yuma how about also
in Israel the border with Egypt in 2013
again
not ancient history but relat relatively
recently Israel reinforced their wall it
cut illegal crossings into Israel to
almost zero a massive drop in illegal
crossings outside of Israel in Morocco
there's a wall between Morocco and
Algeria Morocco was fighting off a
terrorist campaign during the Cold War
by Algeria's proxy the Polisario Front
polisario front law strength after
Mexico built a 1700 mile wall so we here
it's impossible you can't build even 200
miles well they built a 1700 mile wall
wall fences minefields ditches all these
sorts of things what happened it worked
it stopped the attacks it kept the
country safe how about in Cyprus so now
we're moving a little a little closer to
home the the claim that we hear it now
on the immoral side is that walls are
illegal walls are immoral walls violate
international law except they don't they
don't violate international law in
Cyprus the United Nations built a wall
they built a wall in Cyprus dividing a
Cyprus between the northern Turkish
population in the Greek section after
Turkey invaded in 1974 was that against
international law no the international
lawmaking body is the group that built
it India Pakistan India Pakistan have
been fighting for a very long time wars
in 1947 1965 1971 1999 killed millions
of people India built a wall along its
border to deter Pakistani terrorist
attacks and it has worked and it's very
important there we would know if it
doesn't work because those countries
have nuclear weapons and they could send
us all up in smoke
but the wall worked how about Turkey and
Syria so the in Turkey the Kurdistan
Workers Party was it from Syria was
attacking turkey turkey decided to
reinforce its border what did they use
they used all the things everybody else
used they used fences they actually use
minefields they use no-man's land and
for the next 15 years after they built
that wall everything remained relatively
peaceful and quiet and
surely the attacks only picked up again
after air21 the current leader of turkey
started removing parts of that wall and
dismantling parts of that border
security how about in Europe how about
Hungary Hungary built a border wall
because they were being inundated with
with migrants from the Middle East
inundated constantly they were a port of
entry they built that wall it dropped
illegal crossings down to just about
zero and again back to the beautiful old
United States in El Paso they built the
wall a section of border fencing along
there during the five-year period after
they built that fencing illegal
crossings dropped 89 percent and there's
been a recent uptick because the Trump
economy has been so good even with the
recent uptick illegal crossings are
still below pre fence levels where do
other walls work are there walls work at
homes prison schools the Vatican forts
castles movie studios and gated
communities they work in all of those
places so why can't they work here
what's the problem we've already done it
it has already worked here some
conservatives I think that they have
this line which I understand I used to
say things like this which is well the
wall it doesn't really matter it matters
from a symbolic point of view it matters
because Donald Trump needs to show that
he's keeping his campaign promise it
shows because as a symbol it is keeping
people away and it's saying we're not
going to tolerate illegal aliens all of
that is true also it it works to deter
migrants it actually keeps them out
these numbers that keep popping up
ninety percent eighty nine percent 90
percent there's a reason why people have
built walls for all of human history
because they do work and and the this
last example this gated community you
know gated communities have walls this I
think is the analogy for the United
States the United States is the gated
community of countries with the nicest
country we've got the nicest people it's
all really pleasant there everyone's
basically happy we've got a ton of money
and people want to come in and rob us
people want to come in and get get some
of that sweet sweet loot and people in
gated communities don't have gates these
they hate every
on the outside but because they don't
want to talk to everybody on the outside
because they never want to leave their
gated community or anything to do
business with people outside the gate of
course not they have the gate up because
people are posing a threat to them on
the inside because they have really nice
stuff and they want to keep it is
they've got a nice little community we
are the gated community of countries we
should build the gate we should build
the wall now how do we get out of this
shutdown because this is the probe we're
still in this shutdown now I think we're
on day 475 it's the longest shutdown in
American history no what are we're on 34
maybe something like that how do we get
out of this shutdown the current
suggestion be apparently being floated
to by the to the president reportedly
from Jared Kushner is to give green
cards to 700,000 daca or dreamers the
people who were brought here but when
they were under the age of 18 some of
whom now are 40 years old I mean the
people keep continue to age they're not
all cute little kids you know sitting
around with saying googoo gaga over time
this problems been unaddressed and so
you've got these older people here now
700,000 put on a path to legalization
that's a lot that's a lot to pay for a
wall that Democrats voted for 10 years
ago it doesn't seem like a great idea in
fact it seems like a terrible idea it's
the sort of idea I think that would be
embraced by the wall street journal'
kind of Republicans it would be embraced
by liberal Republicans moderate
Democrats they say ok it's fine we don't
really care about immigration like walls
don't even really work we're just doing
this to kind of get out of a tight Jam
politically it's a symbol blah blah No
the reason we want the wall is because
we need to be able to control our
country we need to be able to control
our electoral system we need to be able
to control our government there was a
poll that showed that the majority of
Americans do not simply want to end
illegal immigration they want to
dramatically reduce legal immigration
currently our immigration regime permits
1.2 million people to come into this
country every year the majority of
Americans according to polling want to
drop that number to about half a million
which is still pretty good we take in so
many more immigrants in this country
than anybody else in the world so I
it's insane to say okay we'll take in
half a million people a year and in a
country of 300 million people it's still
a lot of people every year rather than
more than double that but the reason we
want the wall is because when we all
take people in that's fun that's all
well and good when the people come in
though in order for that not to
destabilize our country that they need
to assimilate they need to speak English
they need to like our culture that needs
to like our customs they have to get on
board with the projects that we're all
doing together
the other reason is Democrats realize
that a great many immigrants the
majority of immigrants from a lot of
places identify as Democrat they
continue to vote in blocks
you know the Italians when they came
here they they came to America they were
ashamed of where they came from they
quickly learned English and they
assimilated they assimilated so much so
that you can't predict an Italian
Americans political views I descend from
Italian immigrants on my mother's side
Nancy Pelosi descends from Italian
immigrants and equal modus ends from
Italian immigrants Antonin Scalia
descends from Italian immigrants we have
very different political views Justice
Scalia and I compared to Cuomo and Nancy
Pelosi because you can't predict how
someone's going to vote by that
ethnicity unfortunately because we've
got a multicultural regime that is
encouraging people to flood into the
country and not assimilate and actually
not just not assimilate but D assimilate
people who were assimilating now should
revert to some other culture that isn't
actually theirs according to the left
because of that you can predict with
near certainty where the way that people
from certain countries are going to vote
that's a bad thing it means that our
culture isn't doing a very good job of
bringing them in whose fault is that
that's the left nevertheless that's the
problem and so Democrats see that
opportunity and they say oh great so we
can't win elections with Americans but
if we just import huge numbers of people
more than twice as many people as the
country actually wants to take in every
year then we can get them to vote for us
flood the country with our voters and
then we can do whatever we want
that's quite unjust that's not there's
nothing American about that
there's nothing obviously there's
nothing legal about it because of our
illegal immigration problem but there's
nothing fair there's nothing democratic
about that there's nothing liberal about
that so
the wall the wall matters in a very
tangible practical way the reason it
matters is so that we don't flood the
country with people who the country
doesn't want to be here and if in
exchange for building the wall you
legalize nearly a million people who
Democrats are hungry to legalize because
statistically they're going to vote
overwhelmingly for Democrats then it's a
Pyrrhic victory what have you
accomplished you've built the wall but
you've legalized all of the people that
the wall is meant to discourage what's
the point of that oh great we built the
wall and I mean Ann Coulter had that
funny tweet yesterday she said okay if
we if we give amnesty to a million
people in exchange for 200 miles as long
if we give amnesty to a billion people
maybe we can get the whole wall that'd
be great but what's the point there
You've you bring a billion people in and
then you you don't have a country
anymore it's a very bad idea I hope the
president doesn't take it seriously and
I hope that it's being floated out there
to get the opinions of president Trump's
base in which I find myself let's make
it clear that's this is not what we want
the Democrats will fold on this nobody
cares about this shutdown it isn't real
it's hurting some federal workers that
said the vast majority of Americans
don't care about it many people don't
even know that the government is shut
down it's not affecting their lives the
president was elected to build the wall
and stop illegal immigration the
majority of Americans want to reduce
legal immigration this is a winning
issue don't fail don't flop on it what's
the point of that they would have
elected Democrats if they wanted you to
do this so don't I mean the Democrats do
this all the time because they control
the media they're able to make it seem
like there's this huge public pressure
to give them exactly what they want no
they want you to pass what will end up
being a very unpopular policy it's a
trick it's a trap don't fall for it very
bad idea
we got to get to these Covington kids -
he's coming - there are more new
developments you thought you had seen it
all with that absolute media hit job
well now we see there was initially this
very short video floating around the
internet and then this Twitter account
this mysterious Twitter account posted
it
and said these kids are harassing a
Native American the Twitter account is
now gone turns out it was a fraudulent
account we don't know if this account
was from some foreign agent trying to
stir up trouble we don't know who it is
but it's been taken off of Twitter when
all of the video came out we found out
that narrative was completely false it
was completely flipped on its head but
that was not before the mainstream media
parts of the Catholic Church a ton of
Democrat politicians even many
conservative pundits piled on these kids
with no evidence most of the
conservatives at this point have
apologized most of the other people have
not apologized now alon omar that
freshman congresswoman from the
democrats is doubling down she tweeted
out quote the boys were protesting a
woman's right to choose and yelled it's
not rape if you enjoy it they were
taunting five black men before they
surrounded Phillips and led racist
chants Sandman's family hired a
right-wing PR firm to write his non
apology yeah it's a non apology because
he's got nothing to apologize for you
have something to apologize for alon
omar has hypnotized the democrats i pray
that video footage will awaken them to
the evil doings of elon omar and points
to those of you who caught that
reference so the boys were protesting a
woman's right to choose okay
they were protesting the slaughter of
millions of babies
60 million babies since roe v-- wade
that's what they were protesting why
were they protesting it because well
because it's the wholesale slaughter of
60 million babies as roe v-- wade also
because they're Catholic but the
Democrat Party despises religious
freedom and particularly Catholicism
these days we see this in dianne
feinstein trying to disqualify judges
for being catholic Kamala Harris to
trying to do exactly the same thing
they're more alleges that they were
shouting it's not rape if you enjoy it
there's no evidence of this there there
it was some video of some other people
around them because they're other people
obviously came into the melee and
someone may have said that but it seems
to have been in response as a joke
albeit maybe a bad joke to some of the
black Israelites but we don't even know
and now it's being alleged that that
person doesn't go to Covington Catholic
the reason that we have
believe the kid didn't go to Covington
Catholic his because there were a lot of
girls around there to Covington Catholic
is an all-boys school so I don't know
where this kid was from certainly that
wasn't by the way that wasn't in the
original video so the fact that Ilan
Omar is doubling down on this is absurd
they're just trying to distract because
they can't admit that they were wrong
now Ilan Omar while not apologizing and
while not apologizing for that tweet did
delete the tweet because she knew it was
a terrible look I mean just a terrible
idea
the other new information we've gotten
in the last few days is that Nathan
Phillips you remember that Native
American elder Vietnam veteran how dare
are these kids disrespect him they
approached him they harassed him turns
out none of that's true he approached
them he harassed them he banged a drum
in their face and it turns out he's not
a Vietnam veteran he didn't even fight
in Vietnam which was the headline blared
on every newspaper for the past three
days Washington Post a Vietnam veteran
where are those retractions he was a
veteran he served
I think 1972 to 76 something like that
but he he did not serve in combat he did
not serve in Vietnam and I bring this up
I mean good for him for serving at all
but I bring this up because he's using
this phrase Vietnam times veteran and
he's allowing this misinformation to go
around all the mainstream a Vietnam
veteran Vietnam veteran the phrase
Vietnam times veteran when you use it to
boast about yourself is an intentionally
misleading phrase which is crafted to
imply wrongly that you served in combat
in Vietnam that's what it's about he had
said look I'm a veteran say okay you're
a veteran good good for you for putting
on the uniform that's what that's a
great thing
Thanks say I'm a Vietnam Times veteran
so what was that was that wasn't that
second word and I called it I knew it I
said the first show back I said he uses
the strange phrase I wonder what that is
I didn't want to accuse him obviously
without evidence because I'm not a
member of the mainstream media so if I
had been for the Washington Post
I would have immediately had a giant
headline this guy's a dirty rotten
monster who didn't serve in Vietnam but
then I waited this is what journalists
are supposed to do you wait for the
information to come out it turns out our
hunch was right
he didn't serve in Vietnam he also is a
huge jerk we now know that as well he's
a gigantic jerk it turns out that he led
just but just around the day of this
incident 20 Native Americans to disrupt
a vigil mass it was occurring this was
just reported from the Catholic News
Service
he broke tried to break into a church
and disrupt a vigil mass because he's a
huge jerk they said it was scary the
people inside this unfortunately the
guards were basically able to keep him
out
he's a lunatic he's a lunatic and he's a
liar and the mainstream media are
lunatics and Liars I don't know which
they are most of the time I guess
they're not mutually exclusive the now
we're seeing the replay of this Brett
Kavanaugh incident we're seeing the
replay almost exactly with this kid
Nick Sandman who was the leader of the
Covington students he was the one
sitting there standing there while the
Native American bang to drum in his face
so now he's getting the full Cavanaugh
treatment he was brought on the Today
Show to discuss his experience do you
feel from this experience that you owe
anybody an apology do you see your own
fault in any way as far as standing
there I had every right to do so I don't
I my position is that I was not
disrespectful to mr. Phillips I respect
him I'd like to talk to him I mean in
hindsight I wish we could have walked
away and avoided the whole thing but I
can't say that I'm sorry
sort of listening to him and standing
there this morning sixteen-year-old Nick
Sandman standing by his actions in this
moment gone viral
the junior at Kentucky's Covington
Catholic High School now the face of
this Lincoln Memorial confrontation with
Native American elder Nathan Phillips
con freeze the face of the confrontation
first of all no he isn't Nathan Phillips
is the face of the confrontation because
he started the confrontation he marched
up out of nowhere and started banging a
drum in some poor kids face he is the
face of the confrontation the victim of
the confrontation is Nick Sandman this
kid but I love his answer he died
not have had the restraint that he has I
wouldn't have had the restraint on the
National Mall I wouldn't have had the
restraint on the Today Show say so do
you apologize for your actions do you
feel bad for what you did said uh no I
don't feel sorry for standing and having
a Native American bang a drum in my face
I'm not sorry fry that's not a sin I
don't know how familiar you are with
mortal and venial sins but this is not a
sin to stand there and take abuse from
some lunatic Native American activists
banging a drum in my teenage face you
freaking hack so he handled himself with
incredible maturity incredible restraint
you'll remember by the way the
comparisons between this and Brett
Kavanaugh I would have gone the Cavanagh
route I would have gone out there guns
a-blazing I know Savannah I'm not sorry
I still like beer I like beer sometimes
I drink too much when I drink too much I
don't bang drums in teenagers faces
because I'm a normal person not a
lunatic actor I don't disrupt vigil
masses this is the Cavanaugh incident
they might as well call it Cavanaugh
ington high school at this point in
Kentucky it's the parallels are exact
and and there are people by the way
members of the media who posted pictures
of the two of them because for some
people what this is really about is how
much they hate white guys specifically
conservative white guys Nathan Phillips
is Christine Blasi Ford here he's even a
little kooky Irv Ison just a little bit
that's what it is
he's Christine Blasi Ford Nathan
Phillips is a demonstrable liar whose
story keeps changing and who the
mainstream media keep giving cover to
even after the story changes and changes
and changes it's a Sarah Sanders put it
perfectly I've never seen people so
happy to destroy a kid's life when that
becomes the norm in the media in America
simply because they're associated with
this president that is disgraceful and
that should never happen let's hope that
this is a lesson to all of the media to
everyone let's focus on getting things
right not getting them first I've never
seen people more excited to destroy
someone's life since Breck
since they were so they were begging to
destroy brick Cavanaugh is not a
teenager though you would have thought
he was a teenager from everything they
were talking about what he did when he
was 16 what he did what was written in
his high school yearbook it's this it's
unbelievable two parallels and they
really wanted to destroy this guy Brett
Kavanaugh who had unimpeachable
character federal judge for 12 years no
one ever questioned his integrity until
Donald Trump appointed him for something
what about this poor kid what did this
kid ever do oh he wore a make America
great again had he associated with a
symbol that Donald Trump uses and so and
so they had to destroy him the only
honest take on this was from the left
wingers on the view many people admitted
they made snap judgments before these
other facts came in but isn't that we
just instantly say that's what it is
based on what we see in that moment and
then have to walk step back when it
turns out we're wrong why is that why is
do we keep making the same mistake
because we're desperate to get Trump out
of office
I think that that's the reason I think
the press jumps the gun a lot because we
just we have so much circumstantial
evidence against this guy that we
basically how hoping that you know
Cohen's got the goods and what have you
and so it's wishful thinking right but
let's talk about the kids in this
particular thats the question at hand
you also have some supporters that also
jump to judgment too so I wouldn't say
it's all to get Trump out of office I
think a collective we as a society jump
to judgment today and you believe
whatever you want to believe if you see
that video and it helps the narrative
that you believe in then I think we're
quick to jump on that that's right
that's exactly what joy Behar's right
the reason that they jumped on this is
because the left is so desperate to get
Trump out of office and a be the the one
sort of more right leading person on the
view Megan McCain I guess is there to
but a be certainly that is that way she
says look you see what you want to see
you see what you want to believe which
is half right that's certainly true of
the left the left saw that video and
they saw what they wanted to see and
they ran with that narrative and some
right-wingers saw what they wanted to
see they wanted the the right-wingers
who opposed Donald Trump saw these nag a
hat wearing kids and they immediately
condemned them National Review said they
should have might as well have spit on
the cross and really reactionary stuff
luckily at least the conservative ones
apologized I'll tell you what I did
though when I saw that video I didn't
see what I wanted to see I didn't react
to having seen what I wanted to see
I just kept quiet for like 12 hours like
12 hours it wasn't like I stayed quiet
for a week I said boom this is
inconclusive I don't know what this
means maybe I'll keep my mouth shut for
like 12 hours and see what happens and
I'm very glad I did that because 12
hours later an hour of video came out
and flips the entire narrative it's
basically the left that saw what they
wanted to see the broad broadly the the
right and independence didn't see what
they wanted to see they saw a video they
didn't know what they were quite looking
at because it was a very quick video
that was very inconclusive then they
waited for 12 hours and then it was fine
this is not
Oh shucks it's all of our fault oh gosh
darn it we all have to do better know
the left has to do better and some
trigger-happy people on the right have
to do better too but broadly speaking
the right broadly speaking people in the
middle independents it's not that they
have to do better it's the left it's the
mainstream media it's politicians it's
parts of the Catholic Church it's
everyone who piled on those kids and
didn't apologize okay we've got to talk
about how New York is now legalizing
abortion up until the date of birth you
you know you're nine months pregnant
you're thinking oh oh I might be going
into labor pains soon time to get an
abortion you can now do that in New York
State because of the sick governor there
Andrew Cuomo we will analyze that we
will analyze the the case for life in
the case for death how it effects New
York how it effects all the way over to
the Netherlands but first I've got a
second bite of Facebook in YouTube
coming up next Tuesday January 29th tune
into our next episode of daily wire
backstage state-of-the-union
edition maybe you know if they have the
state of the union daily wire god-king
jeremy boring ben shapiro Andrew clave
and Alicia Kraus and myself little ol me
will be smoking stogies breaking down
Trump speech separating the Magga from
the non Magga I will be just hoarding
all of the mag I will be bathing myself
in it and enjoying those sweets we left
as tears as always only daily wire
subscribers get to ask the questions so
make sure to subscribe today ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me the Andrew flavin show the ben
shapiro show your test questions in the
mailbag coming up tomorrow by the way
get your mailbag questions in you get to
ask questions on backstage you get
another Kingdom you get everything you
get everything and you get this you get
that mmm mmm this blend makes me smirk
this one makes me splurt smirk this is
the covington high school blend this is
the entire mainstream media apparatus
humiliates and destroys itself blend mmm
oh I've never wanted to smirk more mmm
somebody start banging on a drum I want
to smirk even warm mm-hmm go to daily
where calm we'll be right back
New York is legalizing abortion up until
the date of birth which I think I think
of the date of birth we can all agree
that you just call that infanticide so
now the day before birth do you call
that infanticide no the left calls and
abortion and calls it women's health or
a woman's right to choose this is a
pretty sick governor of New York Andrew
Cuomo how do you how exciting is today
we're gonna kill a lot more babies we're
gonna kill them right up until the day
of birth how exciting and then all
everybody in the press yeah yeah yay
it's almost comical if it weren't so
tragic it's it is farcical that's
certainly the case it's it's great how
exciting is today we now get to kill
eight and a half month old babies in the
state of New York that's all this is
about reproductive justice that's all
that this is about I've met Andrew Cuomo
on two occasions I was his waiter one
time when I was in high school and then
I was wandering around New York right as
hurricane sandy was happening and I ran
into him walking around the street this
guy is a pretty tough hombre this guy is
a pretty no-nonsense Bulldog like
character he clearly has higher
political ambitions his father didn't
run for president though he was expected
to they called him Hamlet on the Hudson
Andrew Cuomo says he's not gonna run for
president this time around he clearly
wants to be the president he's been in
politics his whole life Cuomo initially
positioned himself as a sort of moderate
Democrat now he's running far to the
left and that's what this is all about
this is about his future political
ambitions in a democrat party that no
longer believes abortion should be safe
legal and rare it believes that you
should be able to kill a baby on the
very day that he's about to be born
that's what they believe
at least they're honest Andrew Cuomo is
an old Hillary Clinton guy he went with
the transition team in 1992 to help out
the transition he never left he stuck
around Bill Clinton's administration
until the very end of it he's been close
with Hillary for a long time he invited
Hillary to the stage well he announced
the new reproductive law were the the
ironically named reproductive law
because it's about the opposite of
reproduction it's about killing a baby
that's about to be born he goes on was a
pioneer and a crusader for women's
rights and LGBTQ rights before many of
the people in this room were even aware
of the fight there brooklet god bless
you god bless you probably a poor choice
of words from the governor just a rule
of thumb if you are announcing that
you're going to kill many many many many
more babies best not to invoke God I
don't think he takes kindly to that sort
of thing it's also ironic how he's
talking about that he says this is all
about women's rights that's what about
the 30 million baby girls who were
killed between roe v wade and today what
about them I said about their rights 30
million about a lot more people would
have turned out to the women's March if
those 30 million women were still alive
if they hadn't been killed before they
were born only a few thousand people
maybe 10,000 people turned out to the
women's march across the country over
the weekend but 30 million more women
would have really helped but too bad not
about women's rights LGBTQ rights he
says oh they're it's all about LGBTQ
we're already seeing sex selective
abortion in the United States sex
selective fertility certainly in the
United States we're already seeing gene
edited babies around the world we see a
lot of selection when it comes to
abortion and fertility around the world
when they identified the gay gene but
this is what scientists are looking for
this is what the the left's premise you
know you're born this way this is what
this leads true that there's a gay gene
do we really believe that people won't
select against the gay gene the whole
argument from the LGBT left is that it's
it's stigmatized that it's looked on
with opprobrium to be gay or transgender
if that is true and if people are also
ended
they're babies from hole scratch if
they're if they're designing their
babies do we really think that they're
not going to select against that they
already select against women they
already prefer men to women they already
prefer baby boys to baby girl's this has
been borne out in a lot of public
opinion surveys they already kill people
with mental disabilities
Iceland laughed about this they said
this is so wonderful they bragged they
said we have eliminated Down syndrome in
Iceland no you just kill all the Down
syndrome babies you haven't eliminated a
thing other than their lives so the
irony here and so for women's rights
it's for LGBTQ rights baby girls and gay
gay babies are going to be selected
against by this eugenicist agenda it's
already happening and it's already being
discussed as a real possibility he goes
on agenda in Washington it's their
morality it's their interpretation of
religion it's their interpretation of
ethics and they're going to impose it on
you which by the way in this upside-down
world is a total repudiation of
conservative theory because remember the
conservative said limited government
limited federal government because the
federal government they don't know
anything
state government local government
people's rights but limited government
right uh-huh that's true there's nothing
anti conservative about laws against
murder I don't this is such a straw man
I don't know if andrew Cuomo is stupid
or obtuse it could be either I don't
think he's a stupid man but he's making
a stupid argument does any conservative
think that laws against murder are wrong
because it's big government or they're
conservatives marching saying we need to
repeal laws against murder get the
government out of our killing ID no of
course not the government exists to
protect life primarily that's its first
charge even libertarians to protect life
and liberty you can't protect Liberty
without life this is such a shoe
but argument there are laws against
protecting life or not contrary to any
conservative or even libertarian point
of view he says oh well it's contrary to
conservative philosophy conservative
ideology what are you talking about he
says they're trying to impose their
morality on us right and you're trying
to promote your immorality and impose it
on us right politics is about moral
questions this one of the stupidest
lines you ever hear in politics is you
can't legislate morality get morality
out of politics what that doesn't even
mean anything that is a statement that
has the same semantic value as no that's
what it means it has that meaning value
what politics is the affairs of people
politics is how people live together and
govern what each other govern themselves
live in civil society what people care
about are moral questions what people do
has moral value because there is a moral
law and we are moral beings so if I took
this mug and I drink my leftist tears if
I take this leftist here's tumbler and
hurl it at Colton's head and knock them
in the head that is immoral it has moral
value what we do has moral value as
people when we say we need to raise
taxes on the rich because the rich have
too much money you're making a moral
argument when Andy Cuomo is standing
there saying we need women to have the
right to kill their babies he is making
a moral argument we're always making
moral arguments but really he's making
an immoral argument he's saying we need
to kill babies with the right is saying
as we know we shouldn't kill babies one
no those aren't morally equivalent those
aren't that's not a relativistic Oh
question one is right and one is wrong
he's on the wrong side of this he says
conservatives have the world upside down
I talk about this all the time it's true
the conservative worldview must look
upside down to Andrew Cuomo who is a
leftist because leftism gets everything
exactly backwards it gets it's so
backwards that now strength is weakness
they've now justices in justice that now
stealing money from somebody is is
compassion and generosity
and keeping your own money is greed that
that's a crazy that's a crazy
upside-down world and and there's a line
from I think it's your rip ADIZ in the
back I he says talk sense to a fool and
he calls you foolish Andrew Cuomo must
think that this entire conservative
worldview is upside down because he is
standing with his feet firmly planted on
the ceiling he's looking at the entire
world is the sky is there anything
creepier than a man advocating abortion
is there anything on earth yeah we oh
come on yeah women I can't wait to kill
all of those babies that we've given you
and take away all of our responsibility
yeah isn't this great I'm a great guy so
so creepy the way that you know he's
wrong though after all of this after all
this creepy press conference he's given
with Hillary Clinton they're sort of
stirring her cauldron she's she is
directly stage right of Andrew Cuomo
right now and if you can't see it I know
she's not on screen in this clip but
what you can just imagine is her sitting
there you know that giant spoon a ladle
in her cauldron up until the day of
birth so she's doing that right after
the press conference she hopped she
turned to that that stick into a
broomstick and then flew right out of
the the area the way that you know that
this is all wrong is that he can't just
say abortion that's how you know he's
wrong that's how you know that on a deep
level he knows that he's wrong he can't
just say we're gonna make abortion
League
up until the day of birth he can't say
that he says we are going to give women
control of their own bodies the baby's
not their body it's genetically unique
it's another human
it's spiritually unique it's got its own
face it's got its own little hands it's
got its own little fingers it's got its
own little heart it's a it's a different
person it's your child it has a
connection to you not just an umbilical
cord it's your child it does have a
connection right you're not supposed to
kill your children that's wrong in
nature sometimes animals kill their
children you're a person you're not
supposed to do that that's immoral to do
says oh it's reproductive justice it's
not reproductive it's the opposite of
reproductive it's not even contraceptive
it's just infanticide he just can't say
abortion if abortions fine then shout it
I give that one woman credit to shout
your abortion woman please she's honest
shout your abortion if you're so proud
of it if you think that's a good thing
shout it shout it from the rooftop and
don't use these ridiculous euphemisms
euphemisms or the way that you know that
someone is being dishonest that someone
is trying to deceive you yesterday was
the 46th anniversary of Roe vs. Wade
which made abortion legal throughout the
United States we are talking about a
slippery slope here obviously there's
the immediate tangible effect of Roe
versus Wade 60 million babies have been
killed in the United States since 1973
killed before they were born 60 million
and that don't think that that's a scare
number from some conservative site
that's from the Guttmacher Institute
that was part of Planned Parenthood
that's a pro-choice choice pro-abortion
organization that gives that number it's
a conservative conservative lowercase C
number what is the conclusion of that
the conclusion of that is it's no longer
safe legal and rare the conclusion is
Andy Cuomo saying hey folks isn't this
exciting
and the conclusion of that you see in
the Netherlands which is a culture of
death today in the Netherlands 25% of
all deaths come by forms of euthanasia
and suicide and euthanasia is just a
euphemism for suicide it's got the EU
right in it euthanasia euphemism in 2015
in the Netherlands
431 people were killed by doctors
without asking for it which is no longer
suicide that's murder this now the
slippery slope of assisted suicide
compassionate suicide allowing people to
escape suffering has now been expanded
to making it legal for the government to
kill people who have dementia to kill
people who have mental problems 83
people in 2017 were killed in the
Netherlands because they had mental
deficiencies babies with diseases are
regularly killed in 2018 last year a
Dutch doctor killed a 74 year old woman
who was begging him not to kill her 74
year old woman she had some dementia
he gave her a cup of poisoned coffee and
she would not drink it she said no I
don't want to die I don't want the
coffee he made her drink it she pushed
it away she wouldn't take it he then
told the the woman's husband and
daughter to hold her down while he
administered the poison murdered her
right on that bed euthanasia compassion
assisted suicide isn't it better isn't
it better that's the culture of death
that's what roe v wade gives you that's
what the left is celebrating 46 years of
that and can you only imagine what the
country will look like 46 years from now
if we don't overturn it that's our show
tune in tomorrow get your mailbag
questions in I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case production
assistant Nick shyam hair and makeup is
by Jessa
of era the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19